digamos que [ __ ] el de aquí piensa que
es muy buen inversionista ok así que lo
que hace es o más bien tiene una idea y
dice mira voy a crear una corporación y
voy a juntar mucha gente para contribuir
contribuir con dinero y luego yo
administrar su dinero y luego tal vez
come un poco de dinero para mí para que
pueda tal vez contratar analistas o
computadoras o tener una oficina así que
lo que hace es montar la corporación
digamos que monta a la corporación justo
aquí y digamos que tiene cuatro acciones
ok entonces estoy haciendo el número
realmente pequeño solo para hacer el
dibujo y las matemáticas fáciles esto no
sería realista normalmente son miles de
acciones verdad o incluso todavía más
pero digamos que tiene cuatro acciones y
todas ellas son propiedad de pitt
inicialmente sólo para simplificar la
explicación ok y pone 400 dólares en su
corporación ok
aquí están los 400 dólares así que otra
forma de pensarlo es que en vez de que
él ponga 400 dólares en su corporación
es que tiene cuatro acciones y cada una
vale 100 dólares
ok cada una siendo cada una de estas
acciones de por aquí y así que lo que
hace es que registra su corporación y
estoy hablando de un caso específico de
eeuu verdad pero hay muchos tipos de
organizaciones en otros países pero
bueno él registra esta organización de
aquí con la sec de eeuu y la comisión de
valores y también se registra el mismo
en la seca porque estos son sus siglas
en inglés por supuesto y mejor aún
registró una compañía administradora que
corre con la seca así que vamos a
llamarle [ __ ] inc es una corporación que
le empieza y que también registra con la
seca correcto y cuando registra con la
sec les dice bien en esta compañía de
aquí vamos a emitir más acciones para
que más gente contribuya y yo voy a
administrar este dinero de aquí sólo
tomaré un porcentaje del total ok de los
activos bajo gestión a veces sólo verás
que se usa a bg eso significa activos
bajo gestión eso irá a pitt en cada año
por averiguar el mejor lugar para
invertir ese dinero y usualmente es del
orden del 1% a veces un poco menos a
veces un poco
1 % el que va a tomar el dinero que va a
tomar [ __ ] justo ahora solo con 400
dólares eso nos daría 4 dólares por año
verdad pero como se registró con la secc
puede llamarse a sí mismo un fondo
mutualista y puede solicitar fondos del
público que así que es un fondo
mutualista o mutuo asaltado por todos
los aros que la cec le pone correcto así
que puede venderse como algún tipo de
gran administrador o qué sé yo no
sabemos si eso es cierto o no y también
puede solicitar fondos del público
así que del público del público y vamos
a ver en futuros vídeos que hay otros
fondos especialmente los fondos de
inversión libre en ese no pueden
anunciarse y no pueden tomar fondos del
público eso solo pueden tomar fondos de
ciertos tipos de inversionistas
sofisticados digamos y lo que pasa en el
fondo de pib y que será un fondo mutuo
de inversión abierta que estamos
mostrando justo aquí y muchos de los
fondos mutualistas son así digamos que
digamos que leo viene le gusta la labor
de venta de pitt y dice quiero que [ __ ]
administre mi dinero también así que leo
va y le da 100 dólares y dice [ __ ] dame
una acción así que [ __ ] crea otra acción
de aquí creado atracción aquí y se la da
a leo
así que le obtiene su acción y en cambio
le da los 100 dólares para el fondo así
que ahora el fondo tiene 500 dólares ok
esto de aquí son otros 100 y ahora la
cuota anual de pitt va a ser de 1% de
todo esto o 5 dólares al año y si todo
esto crece digamos que todo esto se
duplica de 500 dólares digamos que se va
a 1000 entonces dos mil se reparten
esencialmente en esencialmente entre
estas cinco acciones ahora ok así que
todas las personas tendrían
esencialmente su dinero duplicado menos
los gastos de pizza del año pasa y aún
después de pagarle a pitt el 1 por
ciento y teníamos 500 dólares de bienes
bajo gestión todos estos bienes bajo
gestión
un año después van a van a digamos que
van a un a mil dólares así que pitt es
realmente bueno o realmente suerte hubo
un poquito de ambos tal vez así que
ahora está en mil dólares
déjenme dibujarlo así aquí está en mil
dólares y aún tiene los mismos cinco
inversionistas aquí y leo el suertudo de
ser uno de ellos verdad así que aquí
están los cinco inversionistas déjenme
dibujar las acciones una dos tres cuatro
cinco acciones muy bien ahora cada una
de estas acciones bueno a los mil
dólares se les llama el valor unitario
de la cuota parte ok el book vamos a
llamarlo books sólo para darle un poco
de terminología al asunto así que hay un
book por cada acción el book por acción
aquí es de 200 dólares aunque si sólo
tomamos el total del buque y lo
dividimos por las acciones y lo que es
especial de los puntos fondos mutuos de
inversión abierta es que el cierre o al
final del día tanto podemos remover
acciones del fondo ok o pueden crearse
otras así en el primer vídeo les mostré
como luego quería comprar una acción ok
y entonces se incrementó el número de
acciones y tuvo que crear una acción
para que la comprará no le vendió una
acción que ya existiera así que puedes
imaginarte que después de este tipo de
de desempeño más gente compraría
acciones así que ahora ellos tendrían
que comprar digamos para hacer las cosas
justas en 200 dólares por acción verdad
así que digamos que cinco más personas
quieren comprar a 200 dólares por acción
así que lo que haría o más bien el fondo
mutuo realmente no speed verdad sino la
corporación crearía cinco nuevas
acciones una dos tres cuatro y cinco si
sólo había una persona ese día pues
crearía una acción si había diez
personas ese día pues crearía diez
acciones muy bien y puedes seguir
haciendo esto y el book de cada una de
estas es 200 dólares así que la de estas
acciones a cada persona y tienen que
contribuir con 200 dólares ok
con esto pone otros mil dólares en la
mesa que ahora [ __ ] puede manejar muy
bien y así el book total para el fondo
es de dos mil dólares en esto en este
caso y [ __ ] tendrá su 1% de cuota por
administración de estos 22 mil dólares
verdad ahora digamos que adelantamos un
poquito el tiempo que vamos a darle un
poquito más adelante
y te empiezan a no tener un buen año así
que digamos que adelantamos a un año tal
que [ __ ] tiene un rendimiento negativo
del 10% así que siempre es hasta en dos
mil dólares y eso es cuando ya has
quitado su cuota de administración tú
empezaste en 2000 dólares
pierdes 10% en un año así que baja a mil
800 dólares déjenme poner esto en un
nuevo color así que ahora está en 1800
dólares no está dibujado completamente
escala pero espero que tengan muy bien
la idea de lo que quiero decir ahora
estamos en 1800 1800 dólares pero aún
tenemos un total de 10 acciones aún
tenemos un total de 10 acciones
y hacer mi mejor intento para dibujar
las 10 acciones 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 y 10
estos deberían ser del mismo tamaño pero
bueno ahora el book por acción será de
1800 dividido entre 10 que son 180
dólares y digamos que leo se asusta
verdad se asustó por este reciente
desempeño y que tiene otros compromisos
de dinero así que dice oye [ __ ] tú
necesitas comprar mi acción de regreso
así que lo que pitt hace es que le
devuelve los 180 dólares y el total del
book perdería 180 dólares verdad baja
quitamos esta acción de aquí y que sería
1800 menos 180 que es 1620 verdad del
book y ellos comprarían de regreso a la
acción de leo así que la cancelan
cancelan una de las acciones pero
fíjense el book por acción no cambia al
reembolsarme la acción no cambia lo que
le ocurre a todos los demás ahora tienes
1620 dividido por nueve acciones y esto
debería darte aún 180 dólares por acción
verdad si dice mis matemáticas bien así
1800 menos 180 te dan 1620 y esto nos
debería dar 180 por acción pero esta es
la naturaleza de un fondo mutuo de
inversión abierta puedes seguir y seguir
creando
acciones o quitando las cuando alguien
quiere su dinero de vuelta esencialmente
compras de regreso a la acción de ellos
dándoles su dinero cuando las compras de
vuelta y remueves la acción así que en
un fondo de inversión abierta puede
permanecer creciendo o encogiéndose
puede seguir agregando o quitando
acciones según sus inversionistas lo
difícil de todo esto desde el punto de
vista del administrador es que ellos
tienen que administrar esto tienen que
administrar esta constante compra y
venta con el público tienen que
administrar todo todo y si lo piensas no
pueden tener todo su dinero invertido en
activos ilíquidos o en reservas
regulares ellos tienen que mantener
cierta cantidad que usualmente desde el
3 al 5 por ciento es una parte digamos
de estos dos mil dólares que es en
efectivo y desde el punto de vista de un
inversionista ellos dirían bueno si soy
bueno invirtiendo debería tratar de
minimizar la cantidad de efectivo que
tengo porque no va a tener un
rendimiento en efectivo porque es
inversión abierta porque los
inversionistas pueden venir y decir ahí
quiero mi dinero debes tener una pequeña
cantidad de efectivo a la mano como
parte de reserva para poder comprar de
vuelta a las acciones